[Applaudissements]
bonsoir et bienvenue dans cette rue
mieux que surveillante rédaction ne
touche pas à mon poste
ils sont dix chroniqueur à la fin il
n'en restera qu'un
[Musique]
salut les branleurs s'affaissant quatre
jours que vous vous battrez comme des
chiens pour conserver votre place dans
la tribu nous allons passer à l'épreuve
de confort à la clé une place de parking
à des 8 es ce que vous avez des
remarques
oui me donner l'épreuve de confort j'ai
personnellement j'en ai à [ __ ]
si on pouvait passer directement à
l'épreuve du poteau passait pas et c'est
bien là qu'il veut grimper sous le lien
directement bush l'accord bravo jean
michel vous venez de remporter l'épreuve
de lourdeur
[Musique]
je sais que quand le moine regarde au
nord eh bien il a le sudoku lemoine
regarde au nord est il a le sudoku
mais bon qu'à jean luc il ya eu certes
un pas quasi monsieur aucune aucune and
one pour pas trop mais je vais chercher
mais voici un petit coffret dans le coin
parce que je commence à me gratter un
peu
[Musique]
place maintenant à l'épreuve
d'orientation vous avez une boussole et
un plan des locaux et vous devez
retrouver le bureau de cyril hanouna
90 degrés je pense 90° s nord-ouest si
c'est bon attends attends pas
super gros problème c'est normal il y
avait un piège c'est ilan ou non n'a pas
de bureau puisqu'il vient jamais les
branleurs c'est l'heure du conseil
vous allez devoir voter pour choisir
celui ou celle qui selon vous doit
quitter l'aventuré ce soir
en tout cas ce ne sera pas moi que j'ai
un gros totem d'immunité voulait le voir
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]